thanks everyone it's great to have you
all here um
we'll be splitting this tutorial in half
so the maxim will start
um first of all we're going to set up
the environment for all of you guys um
so we handed out post-it notes if anyone
doesn't have any
uh please raise your hand
those are to indicate whether you've
already installed your environment
so if you're struggling to install
please put up the red sticker one of us
will come around and help you
and potentially set up set you up with
an environment
um yeah thanks so much maxine will take
it away and
i'll take over halfway through
hi everyone
so i'm maxim i'm working for anaconda
i'm a software engineer there
um today we're going to talk about
hvplot which is a plotting library and
that gives you a lot of power
um we'll start so with this setup so um
i don't know
i could get the screen
so
this uh like the simplest instructions
for you to get set up um you have this
tiny url
link that is pi data hvplot 2022 to get
to this document
where you can find how to
install the environment and the data
sets you will need to run the notebooks
from this tutorial
this uses anaconda project it's a it's
not a it's not the purpose of this
tutorial but it's a super nice
package that allows you to declare your
dependencies the data you depend on and
to package that in a very nice way
there's also a way to install um the
dependencies with pip
uh i recommend you download this zip
file over there
uh it's about 150 megs so might take a
while but it's going to be fine
and then you will find instructions on
how to install the dependencies
in the readme there is a requirements
file
we also provide a binder link but binder
is super limited in resources these days
so it's very likely it's not going to
work but yeah if if you don't manage to
install anything with content and bp you
can try this
um
and if really you can't do anything
actually this whole tutorial
of this tutorial can be found on this
website holovis.org
so the same notebooks we will run
already there executed
just you won't get all the interactivity
so i'm gonna
let you keep uh
working on your setup
and i'm going to do the introduction to
to this tutorial
uh i think when you think your setup
like you have installed the dependencies
and and everything you should try to run
this notebook the zero zero underscore
setup
if you can run it without any warning
without
any
issue
then you're good good to go for the rest
of the tutorial
oh sorry yes
definitely
so it's by data hb plot 2022
at tinyurl.com
oh yes definitely
so when you're set up if you if you can
put this green post it on your on the
back of your laptop so that
i can have an overview of who's ready to
go
excellent idea so for the online
audience
um
you have this document you can access at
this tiny url and it gives you
instructions about how to install um the
dependencies and the data sets and and
to how to obtain the notebooks that we
are going to set you up on with combat
if you don't have contact installed you
can install miniconder first
and you can also install the
the tutorial and the dependencies by
first downloading this zip file
and then
extracting it and you have more
instructions in the readme how to
install the dependencies with beep
you can also try your luck with binder
um it's pretty unlikely it's going to
work because it has limited resources
these days but you can still give a try
remind everyone
yes and and when you're ready everyone
oh i see a lot more greens that's nice
don't forget to put to put a green post
it on the back of your
of your screen
nice
yeah so i'll get started and anyway the
beginning is it's quite a lot of it's a
bit of talking so you still have time to
get set up before we actually run the
examples
um yeah but just to remind you when if
you think you're ready run this notebook
the setup notebook
that is in the examples um in the
tutorial folder if it runs fine you're
good to go for the the remaining part of
this tutorial
i'm gonna zoom in because i think it's
really small right
is it fine in the background screen size
looks right okay
so yeah welcome to this
one bigger
okay thanks
uh so welcome to this tutorial uh this
is the holovis dash um hp plot tutorial
um
holovis so holovis is a set of tools
it's also a group of people who's been
working on these tools for
open source stores for many years i
think about 10 years
they are dedicated to data visualization
and they really
are meant to help you in your data
analysis like workflow
um getting data exploring this data
testing hypothesis on your data by
visualizing it
then when you're fine with your analysis
and you want to generate figures to
share them
with your colleagues and your boss you
may also want to be able to deploy your
your like your plots and your small
dashboards to your colleagues so that
they can interact with the data if they
have more questions
and we also want each stage in this
process uh to be customizable and
that you can improve over time
so that's that's where uh where the k
the name holovis comes from from hollow
that means like whole entire complete
um so doesn't python already cover all
of these stages well sure it does
because it's been there for for like
about 30 years now
this is a view of the
visualization landscape of python it's i
think even a condensed view
so it's a lot of different technologies
and a lot of different packages so you
see
some famous ones like mad plotlib over
there
there are
packages and technologies that are built
on top of javascript some other on top
of d3 or vga
why are there so many too many tools
because they were solving different kind
of problems
so
some uh solve like they allow you to get
very quickly to like in one liner to
simple nice plots
um but then you can't really customize
that much
some uh like madrid lib i think for
example are very good at
creating uh plus that you can print so
it's very good for research for
publication
and some others are good for
interactivity in a jupiter notebook like
like these examples but then they can be
kind of weak or not super performant
when you want to use them in batch
processes so for instance overnight you
want to create tons of figures
of your data
some are good for deployed servers so
you can like have them embed them in a
website
but they don't work so well maybe in
jupiter and as a data analyst data
scientist you want to be able to work in
in your notebook and then to just deploy
the exact same thing in on the server
and finally some are like good at small
data set but suddenly you get a lot more
data and
it's just going to break or be very very
slow and not performant
the whole of this is trying to tackle
all of this
like this sort of weaknesses
by providing an ecosystem
that has all these capabilities
uh part of it at least so it
it's uh holovis is meant to
to work very well in a web browser so in
a jupyter notebook and also on deployed
servers
um
you just write um
python python scripts you don't write
like javascript or front end
um
all the activity all the interactivity
works the same in jupiter as long as in
like on the server
and one thing uh it's almost the
philosophy of hollowves is shortcut not
dead hands
it means that
you will be able to get
pretty quick to a point where you're
satisfied like a plot that you want it
but then you always want to customize it
a little a little bit more
or your boss or colleague says oh maybe
you should do that sometimes you'll get
stuck there with the tool you can okay
i can't do anything more with this too
with with holovis and some of these
packages can always just go a little bit
further and customize uh things more
and so yes as much as possible holidays
tries to use the api that you know and
this is uh
this is really going to be about hp plot
so you see like all of this is this
suite of tools it's a small ecosystem
they all work very well together
i'm going to focus today on hv plots but
there are other ones and there will be
mentioned in in this tutorial
hv plot release the is the entry point
to
the whole ecosystem
it is based so i'll
i'll talk a little bit more about hp
plot later
um panel is a library with which you
write python code and you can create
dashboards that you can deploy
so basically you can create like some
small websites
just writing python code so no
javascript css html
hall of use is what powers hp plot
mostly so it's a way to interact it's a
way to
you create objects that
in a notebook will display themselves as
plots like curves or
points or polygons
it's really a way to wrap your data with
some
options and some
operations that later displays
themselves
geoviews is an extension of holoviews
that so you can map geographical data
and display geographical data
data shader which we will talk about
is a way to
plot really a lot of data so jean-luc
gave a talk yesterday
in the afternoon if you missed it you
can watch
in a few days or weeks on youtube
param is a way to declare so param is
really maybe the library
part of all these libraries that is less
the less dedicated to visualization but
it's also very cool when you write some
algorithms
or to declare your interface when you
when you write some api
it's typed parameters so you declare a
parameter that is a string and then your
users if they use a parameter that is
not a string get an error automatically
it's also more than that but this is
already very useful
so hollovis has decided to
it builds on the under the python
visualization landscape and it has
decided to build
around matlat lib so it supports
matplotlib
it also it also builds on partly
so you're all available to use properly
and bokeh
um and well there's also support for
some other
parts for some for some some other
libraries but it is less it's really
around this
main three
yeah so this is what this diagram shows
here
and so in this tutorial so what you
actually got by installing the tutorial
you have a full long like four hours
tutorial but today we'll focus on the
first part of it that is really
dedicated to hv plots
if you have time and if you feel like it
you can keep going during the tutorial
and you you will learn more about panel
and holo views and how to use these
tools in in a more advanced way
uh the tutorial we reuse earthquake
data sets
and so
we'll we will analyze this data and we
will create small dashboards to
to explore it
and we'll focus on on the first part on
hvplot.plot
so
if you have used pandas before
you may have used the dot plot api so
the dot plot method
to create plots so it's sort of like
flat api with a lot of parameters like
read csv
instead of doing dot plot after
installing h3 plot you can do dot hv
plot
and it re most of the api is
just the same so you can use the same
parameters that you would use for pandas
api
except that it extends it and you get
more power
we also have dot interactive
with which
like you bring interactivity and the
ability to build some pipeline that you
can control with widgets
and you know you will see with example
it's easier to explain with an example
and we'll not talk in this tutorial so
much
about panel but it will be mentioned a
few times
so i'm jumping to the
so uh yeah i encourage you now to to run
the tutorial uh with me
uh the notebooks and there are a few
small examples so i will give you time
when you when we come to them so that
you can run them and just play around
with the data
so i already mentioned the blenders.plot
method
and
hv plot so builds
builds on top of this api but it's not
the only one you have also xray
um you have pandas bokeh so you have
now a collection of tools that have
built on top of the
this api and that is very common to a
lot of users
and i think it's very easy as like to
enter in this world and to just to
create quickly some plots
um
so yeah we'll start by running the
tutorial so we will use pandas to read
uh some data some parque files
but just so that you know um we could
have used like dusk
or we could have used um qdf
like to use your
gpu resources
hvplot allows that so you create you can
create plots from
dataframes if you want to for instance
so i'm just going to read in the data
if you have any problem while running
this thing just let me know
so we have a data set of about
two million points
so we have earthquake events so they
have a time stamp and they have a lot of
different like properties their
magnitude their depth we also have their
locations or longitude electricity
for this tutorial we will just create a
small
data frame with just a fraction of the
data because
2 million points
for some tools is
like too much they can't really handle
that so but we will you will see later
that with hp plot you can handle as many
points as you want
and we will switch between these two
data frames
during the
in this notebook
so first we show with the like what does
the traditional
dot plot method of pandas
do
um
so you call it with dot plot dot scatter
here in this case so we're creating a a
scatter plot
with the longitude as the x-axis and the
latitude as the y-axis
there's a small example here that you
can try so
changing the inline here with widgets
and see what you get so yeah i encourage
you to try that
you'll see that you get actually a
way to interact with this plot
you can zoom in on your plot
you can pan
so this is already
quite nice you get some interactivity
you can't really know what what's the
data
associated with one given point
but it's still a little bit better than
than the pure static plot if you want to
do some exploration
now we'll switch to using um hvplot
directly
so to use h3plot you just need to import
it this way h3plot.pandas
and instead of calling.plot we will
call.hvplot
so what you get is actually a bokeh plot
so
i didn't know how much of you were
aware of this library but it's it's a
python library that i think was started
quite a long time ago at anaconda
and
it
it allows you to interact
so much more it's a it's not a static
plot it's a plot with which you can
interact
so you can pan
you can zoom in with this you have a set
of tools on the right so you can like
zoom in you can zoom in with your
scroll wheel
if you if you zoom in on axis you can
actually just
change things with respect to this axis
and you also have the possibility to
hover data points
and so by default with this data set how
we've configured it you don't get a
super useful information just the
latitude and the longitude but we can
customize that to get for instance the
magnitude
um so you see already you get
by
with with just like a single import
h3plot.pandas and changing.plot to
hvplot
you get a tool that's pretty useful when
you want to explore your data
and more than a static plot
um
yes so there's something that's noted in
this in the comment here is that
um this plot suffers from what is called
overplotting so even though this is the
small data frame and we don't have that
that much data
we can't really
see
the the density
we can't really see the density of all
these
of of the earthquakes we can't really
say anything because we just have too
many points and we haven't really tried
to do anything to
to try to to see that density better
um what you would do really the first
thing you would do and you can try this
out this is the exercise
is you would change the
the transparency of each point
so
well you may try with 10 percent or 20
percent or 50 percent
uh by trying with 10 well you get
something a little bit better you see
that this is
you can you can see this is more than
over here you can start to see the shape
of like
of mountains it's a little bit better
um another way something else you could
have done instead of doing of of um
of creating a scatter plot you could
have created a hex beam
so
by
plotting hexagons
and in each hexagon each hexagon the
colour of each hexagon
represents the density so the number of
earthquake
that were in this area
so
i don't know if it's better it's just
another way to represent the data you're
exploring it
but we'll see better ways to explore the
this data set
um yeah
so
with a flat api like the one like dot
plot
usually you have a lot of options yeah
so it's not super easy to find all the
options you can you're able to pass to
this uh api
so there is a utility hdplot.help
and you pass the string of um like the
kind of plot you want so for instance
scatter and when you try that you'll see
you get a pretty large
output
with all the parameters you can pass
so there are different kinds of
parameters there are generic parameters
they are data shader now we're not using
data shader they would there are
geographic options and at the end at the
very end you will see the style options
these style options are the ones that
are passed to the plotting library the
backend that is bokeh so
when we used alpha but we could have
used all of these other like options to
parameterize how we want our plot to
look like
this utility accepts some parameters so
if you don't want to see all everything
all of that
you can just
select like okay i just want to see the
normal up the normal parameters and the
style parameters
um okay so we saw that the plot we just
created suffered of overplotting we just
had too many plots so we will use data
shader now
to circumvent this problem and
what data shader does is that
it
will create an image instead of like
plotting like all the points it will
create an image and in each pixel
there will be by default the count so
the number of points you would have had
um
you
just to get this data shader plot you
need to you need to specify rasterize is
true
there are options uh to say
uh how the color mapping is spread but
we will use like the
default options by the the option that
is the the most suited for the default
case when you start the first look you
have at this
at your data set
so that that that's a much different
plot right so you don't get points
anymore you get an image
and well you can see
really it's way better you can see the
density you can you can still zoom in
and out
and
the image is recomputed every time you
zoom in and out
and hover
you can also hover over this these plots
and you get on in each pixel so it's
really adapted to your screen each pixel
the count of
earthquakes
so yeah i encourage you to play around
with this kind of plot because it's very
nice
but
can i repeat the question in the
microphone just for the online audience
yes
uh
can you please repeat your question so i
can repeat it can you repeat your
question
a question is is there an easy way to
zoom in and out because this does not
seem easy
i'm just i'm just using the touchpad not
using any
yeah the touchpad may not always work
for everyone and you you also need to
use to select the wilson tool on the
right
that's the way that's the way
okay so this plot actually we were still
using the the small data frame but we
will
now use the
the full data set
and you'll see you get very quickly so
we have over two million points in the
data set
and
it it works very well you would have
tried that uh you would have to pro
you would have tried to plot
to make a scatter plot of all these
points probably your browser would have
crashed because it's it's too it's it's
too many a mad party plot would have
been fine it would have taken maybe a
little bit longer
yes
so um yes
so as i said already but it's fair to
repeat it again so we use uh pandas now
as our entry point but we could have
used the ask
x array
uh there's also support for streams
streams it's uh to support streaming
data
intake there is a
like a library that offers data catalogs
and so you can have an h3pot interface
to that geopandas if you're used to
geodata and also network x for graphs
there's a small exercise
so
if you could try that select the subset
of the data so for instance only the
magnitudes that are greater than five
and plot them with a different color map
so with another c-map parameter
i'm i just gonna give you like one
minute to try that
well from the big data and you can use
um
rasterizing it goes through so repeating
the question for the online audience
subset from the small subset or subset
from this big data set yes thank you
this was the answer to that yes
so i think while we're waiting we've had
another question here as well
okay it's on slider
um is it possible to set the color
the legend to something that looks a bit
nicer because you have a lot of uh
like to have like integers on the colors
uh
integers here yeah
that's scary
this this this color map is actually
it's computed it depends on your data
so i don't think with this option egg
hist you can you can't set the color map
itself
you can you can change the way you
compute the color map
so you can use
log
and here you get something you're more
used to but
you get a little bit less information
yeah and you also have the option to
have linear but linear here it's not
going to be useful at all
because the density is really in some
tiny clusters of the whole data
okay so
this
this is the solution to the
to the small exercise um
you can pass a lot of different values
to c-map
color maps that are supported by
matplotlib bokeh
or and also another package that is part
of holovis that is called color set
next onto statistical plots
so
dot plot like dot hv plot
not only
um
not only support scatter plots but also
you can have like histograms and other
kind of statistical plots so what we
will do first is that um
we will so you
what are we gonna do here oh yeah okay
we're just gonna clean up our data set
to
remove nands
and then we will plot a histogram with
dot plot the dot plot fpi of
i'm going to remove that
with the dot plot api of oh yes
the legend disappeared when you change
the color
the lame question was is it also the
same for you that the legend disappears
when you change the color map
do you mean here there's no legends
oh yeah yeah yes you don't have a scale
anymore it is because it i have used the
data shade option
um if i use rust rice oh it doesn't come
back okay no
messed up
what did i do wrong here
if you remove the column it should show
again okay that doesn't sound like a bug
you can explicitly set color bar equals
true
oh
did that
someone is saying color bar doesn't make
any sense if you have one color
it does make sense because it's not just
one color it's like a a collab of a
color map of reds
so it does make a little sense
uh yeah so
thanks for the question and back back to
the histogram
so just to show you the support that
edgy plot has
to histograms
um you also get so you still get a bokeh
plot so interactive you can hover and
you know how many points you have in
each bin
um
so this is again very useful compared to
a static plot
so the small exercise here if you could
create a kernel density estimate
plot of magnitude
instead of a histogram
it takes a while
so maybe a quick reminder to everyone in
a few minutes we're going to have
a questions round and also for the
online audience if you have any
questions
or comments please put them in slido
and
we'll take questions from there
and then from the live audience
approximately
uh five to ten minutes from now so to
get a kernel density estimate plot you
just have to call h3plot.kde
by specifying that you want it to be
with respect to the magnitude
it's an estimate of the probability
density function
okay and the last uh
part of this tutorial is going to tackle
categorical uh plots
so we will in this dataset add some
categories with respect to the depth of
the
earthquakes
um we'll use this simple table to define
them between shallow intermediate and
and and deep
we're just gonna do some
pandas full
to create these categories and create a
new column insert a new column in our
data frame
i can show you
what that looks like
so we have now a new column called depth
class
with shallow intermediate and and deep
deep earthquakes
and we will we will create a histogram
and by saying that we want to see a
difference with respect to their depth
class
with the buy parameter
what we get here is an overlay of
different histograms
a quick trick is that you can click on
in the legend
to deactivate partly
the plots so that you can see better
those that are underneath
you could start to dig more into your
data set and and try to see what's going
on at like
um
greater magnitudes or if i managed
you still have hover that is working and
you can get over from
multiple histograms in the overlay
small exercise so
add in the previous call subplots equal
true to see what's going on
and width
set to 300 pixels
so with this simple change instead of
getting an overlay you get a composition
of uh
three different histograms
and they actually happen to be linked
so um if you zoom in on one particular
axis on one plot it will also zoom in on
the other plots and same for pen they
are their axes are linked automatically
and
okay so now we've got like an overlay of
three different plots we've got a
composition of three plots but maybe
what you would want is just one plot and
the ability to switch between the plots
and this is what we call grouping
you activate grouping by using the group
by parameter and giving it the name of
one your columns
so you'll see i'll try to get this
maybe
change that a little bit
yeah that's better
so by automatically what you get by
using group by is you get your plot so
here it's a by varied floats
but you also get a small widget that
allows you to
select your
group
your group category
and by changing the value you select
with this widget you get
the ability to explore your data set and
see the differences
to keep going like and now using further
our data set
instead of just classifying by depth we
could classify by magnitude
so we are going to define some magnitude
class and
associate them a name like minor light
moderate strong
and we will create a heat map out of
this
because now we have data set with two
different categories so we have two
different columns with two categories
and so we can pass these two categories
as like a heat map and
each
each bin here each sort of cell will
have the count
of
earthquake events
so
we can see that in this data set we
appear to have like a
where we have the highest density is
like light uh magnitude earthquakes and
and shallow
it's okay so yep so this is the the end
of this first part of the the tutorial
that is really that was an introduction
for you to agree plot i hope you get the
feeling that just by changing just by
doing one import and calling hvlot
instead of dot plot you really get a
tool like with bokeh and with the
possibilities of hp plot and data shader
that is really super powerful and you
don't have to learn like a lot of
different apis
this is quite flat and it you have to
remember just a few parameters or find
them in the documentation
um
so i think we get to the
question time so
if you have questions now
please do so
there are questions online so we'll take
those first and then we can around the
audience
so uh so one question has already been
answered can you please share the github
link these are on discord in room a5a6
the next question is there standard way
to combine uber h3 geospatial index and
hv plot
could you repeat the question i just did
that is there a standard way to combine
uber h3 geospatial index i do not know
what that is right and h websocket uber
like the yeah company yeah or
the german word yeah i think uber gets
you like hex plots
yeah
experts hex hex plots
i think that's an index for in 15
different resolutions to create
hexagons on the over all of the earth
and then it's
mapped to a latitude longitude which is
very nice for aggregating stuff yeah but
plotting hex codes is usually shitty so
i was wondering if there's something
already yeah nice
all right
we have no interface with uh any package
from uber to x
i don't remember the h3 i think it's the
name of this package and we have no
interface to that and we just create a
exploit
like
out of the box from okay
hi hi is there a way
for hd plot to work outside jupiter
notebook
yes so um
you can actually
save your plots
uh so there is like you can do
h3plot.save
on the object that is returned by each
call
and so that's a way to have a static
file
but um we also have a library that's
called panel
and panel is a dashboarding library with
which you can just like deploy and and
create like dashboards and hv plot
objects
you can embed them very well in this
sort of dashboard
okay
hello yeah so i'm getting an error every
time i'm importing hvplot it is asking
me to install a git
i i i say um cancel but every time i do
i even call something to plot it it
opens this window and says um you should
install git um
and i say cancel so i have to every time
say cancel and then it runs okay it
shouldn't do that that's very strange
it's uh okay
we'll have a look okay
okay so is there a link maybe in the
discord where you can file bug reports
absolutely so there is it it's just
hollow on github you can find holovis
slash hb plot and file bug reports there
um
no i think we're good okay a second part
then
yes uh hi everyone i'll take over from
here um okay ah we have it working
perfect all right so we're gonna move on
to the next notebook um if you are
running on our anaconda cluster um
ideally you shut down the previous
notebook when you move on to the next
one just to limit resource usage a
little bit
that's a general advice anyway
all right so so far we've kind of
created simple plots um
but usually you kind of want to combine
different layers in your plots right you
might have a scatter plot and you might
have highlights certain bits
and so you want to have a way to combine
those together or create layouts of
multiple plots and that's what we're
going to be looking at next
so again we're going to load our data
set here
i hope you can see that is that size i
might go one larger
all right uh so we've loaded our data
set again we're going to import hp
pandas
and now we've created kind of we're
going to do some resampling weekly
resampling of this data
to generate us a weekly plot of
earthquakes right
quite nice we get all the interactivity
we're used to
in fact bokeh has nice
daytime access resolution so that when
we zoom in we kind of get more
information about dates
and that's all nice
but what actually kind of kind of
magically all these plots just appear
and how does that actually work well
jupiter has this idea of
representation and this wrapper this
visual wrapper basically appears if you
put an object at the end of a line and
so if i kind of suppress the output put
a semicolon here we don't get any output
and then if we use the print function we
actually
get a different view of this and this is
a textual representation of what this
object is in this particular case this
line plot is a so-called hollow views
curve element
what does that tell us well it gives us
a little bit of information it tells us
kind of this is a plot of earthquake
counts
over time
which is nice um but what does that
affordance actually give us right it's
an object nice enough you're familiar
with not pulled up figures
um
but why is that a nice thing well these
objects you've got a variable on this
object and you can compose these objects
together
so if i do some similar resampling of
kind of
now do
weekly mean magnitudes i now have two
different objects and i can compose
those together in some form right so
i've have this plot of weekly counts i
have this plot of weekly means
i could combine compose those using the
multiply operator and the multiply
operator basically means
stack them on top of each other in this
particular case
it doesn't really make sense right so
really what we want to do is compose
them into a layout
so that's what we can do with this plus
operator instead and that gives us a
layout of these two components
in this case
basically it kind of fills
a number of columns and using this dot
calls
call here we can set to say how many
columns of this do i want right so i can
do two columns but that's a bit too wide
so in this case i do one column and now
i have these two plots composed together
into one i will make this slightly
larger
okay um
that's pretty nice right if you're
coming from um
mypotlib you're used to kind of creating
subplots and this kind of provides an
easy way of composing these plots
together and quickly generating layouts
or composing multiple plots together
um
okay
so
another nice thing we can do
is
adding a third dimension to our plots
right so it's got our plot
has two dimensions it has the x and the
y
but you might want to actually color by
some dimension or you want to scale the
size of the points by some dimension
and hp plot also makes that very easy
just like in the maple lib interface you
can set
the c argument color
to a particular dimension of your data
so here
we can now color our points
by the magnitude and kind of see some
patterns here for example in the pacific
region you have these really intense
earthquakes and similarly here
and
always
this will
all hp plots basically return you a
holovies object and give you a bit of
information about kind of uh what we're
actually plotting so here we're plotting
a scatter plot
of longitude against magnet against
latitude
with scales by uh
where the color is scaled by the
magnitude
so
printing is always a good way to kind of
actually understand what is this thing
that i'm plotting
after the fact
and
next yeah
so we've now created um
one thing that we've kind of have to
think about a little bit which you
usually maybe don't think about so
deeply right you're creating a scatter
plot it doesn't you've got an x you've
got a y
um which one depends on which other one
right
really a scatter plot usually plots some
variable again some other variable
while here really we're plotting
physical locations and so
hollyviews makes this distinction
between
um dependent variables and independent
variables
and uh scatter kind of this doesn't make
sense why is longitude on its own here
and latter two grouped grouped in the
magnet with the magnitude
um
hb plot makes this hp planet and hollow
views make this distinction of
dependent independent variables and here
so
if we say we want to plot longitude and
latitude we really should be expressing
those as points rather than scatter
rather than a scatter plot and that's
just conceptually cleaner because now
we're expressing that kind of magnitude
is a variable of the longitude and
latitude
in some sense rather than plotting them
against each other
okay
[Music]
other things we can add kind of we've
added a color other things we can add
for example we scale by size but we can
also kind of reveal more information
about
our data by kind of adding these hover
columns so basically we have a bunch of
columns in our data frame we want to add
something for more context more
information into this plot
but kind of we don't want to
visually vary too many variables
so we add them to the hover information
and now when we hover over this we get
not just the
longitudinal latitude and the magnitude
but we also get the place and the time
of this earthquake right um so we can
really drill in down into this and get
all the information we want right and
that's a huge benefit of this
interactive plotting mechanism rather
than having something like um live where
it's static and you can't really
just got an image that you're dealing
with
um i think we're gonna
we are running a little bit
low on time so i'm gonna skip this an
exercise and just keep running here
the other thing kind of we've uh the
whole way through here we've kind of
plotted these uh geographic locations
but it's really hard to get a
physical context for where these things
actually are right
so hvplot helpfully includes various
tile sources um so
these come from hollow views are defined
in hull views and so here's a towel
source of kind of esri
satellite imagery and uh we can use that
and now use the multiply operator to
compose
these tiles together with our plot and
now we can actually get an understanding
of kind of where are these points
actually
on this map before you could kind of
guess based on kind of if you knew a
little bit about where
earthquake regions were
but here now we can actually get
physical context right and see well yeah
this is the specific
this is
kind of
just off new zealand for example there's
a ton of earthquakes
so that's quite nice
and um
we don't actually so here we've kind of
shown you that
yes we make this composition of these
two elements right
but in actual fact hbplot helpfully
provides you a tiles argument which lets
you kind of add geographic tiles very
easily
without having to do the
composition um another thing kind of
we've already talked about kind of so
far we've worked entirely with
tabular data pandas in particular
um
but hp plot has support for a wide range
of kind of data libraries and if you're
not familiar with xray it's kind of the
the pandas for
raster data graded data some
sometimes referred as
so basically images right
um
and so we can easily we're just going to
clean up this data a little bit
this
in particular refers to this data set
here that we've already downloaded and
are loading now our population densities
so we want to provide context right so
earthquakes yes it's interesting it's an
interesting data set but really the real
world impact is what we're interested in
and so we're now wanting to combine this
density information with the earthquake
information
we can again use this rasterize argument
um which
kind of helpfully this is a huge image
right this is kind of four thousand by
eight thousand pixels uh dumping that
into your browser
as just an array is it's i think ten
tens of megabytes
and so this rasterized argument just
like in the
um
previous scatter case it re-grids the
data depending on our zoom level right
so as i if i zoom in further we get more
and more detail until we're down to kind
of the resolution of the actual
underlying image
and so in this way we can get a ton of
information about
this data just by
using this rasterize argument
all right and as a final step we're
going to put this all together right
so we have our
rasterized population estimate
density estimate
we've got our scatter points with our
hover information
uh scaled by color and we're going to
now relay those two and get
um
kind of a plot of some of the
most severe earthquakes and how they
relate to the population density
in that region and so this gives us a
lot of context a lot of information and
it's really quite easy right we've kind
of in just a couple lines of code we've
loaded these two data sets
we plotted it we regretted it using
data shader and then we can easily
compose it using this multiply operator
so this is
a super nice and quick way um to kind of
generate uh compositional plots
and
this leads us into kind of the core
philosophy and we want to make things um
low level things
easy
we can kind of choose precisely where to
go
but
in the end we provide a high level api
but in the end you can still drill down
where you need to go you can customize
every little bit of it
and if you kind of drill down further
into this uh really we've kind of
underlying this are just bokeh plots so
if you really need to customize every
single detail about your labels you can
still drill down into kind of
the actual uh bokeh representation of
this and then tweak every little thing
about your plot so if i import
all views here
as hv what we get back is just a bokeh
figure and similarly actually we've just
added support to kind of plotting with
matpot lib and uh with plotly into hp
plot such that using this simple
representation these cost a few lines we
can generate a plot and then still
customize it in very very detailed ways
and that's always been our philosophy in
all of our packages
um
yeah sorry i've been running a little
bit fast and we don't have a ton of time
i'm going to quickly do a
demo of kind of a very powerful feature
in hp plan and then we're going to get
back on track and kind of go through the
last little bit which was the promise of
this tutorial which is to build little
actual data apps
um
using hp plot and some of the tools
around it
so i'm just going to run through this
notebook very quickly and then yeah
we'll go to the next one
and
get some more information so one really
nice feature is
the composition is a really powerful
feature that we get out of the fact that
hp plot is based on hull views the other
nice feature is
that we can um kind of compose things
but then we can also use operations that
are defined in hollow views
to drill down further so there's this
link selections um operation in hollow
views where we can compose two plots um
tell all of these these should be linked
um
and then i can
kind of select that one plot and see
that selection reflected on the other
plot and so this really kind of
very complex and nuanced relationships
in your data can be kind of teased out
this way
and again it's really just a line of
code right you're just
of holoviews does all the hard work of
kind of finding these dimensions are
linked between these two plots and then
figures all of that out and so this
works for
most plot types
here for example we've again got our um
uh got our geographic plot uh with a
slightly different tile source and we've
overlaid a history a histogram of the
depths of the earthquakes and so i can
now kind of tease out where
i can ask questions of this data right i
can say where
are
earthquakes which are very deep in the
earth right and so i can select here on
this histogram to say i only want
earthquakes to show up which are at a
depth of 500 plus or whatever
and immediately this is reflected in the
geographic plot and again
just a single line right we just have
our plots we tell it these are linked
and figures that out and
then links them for us
underneath
this is basically expressed as a
so-called selection expression
so we can look at the selection
expression here
basically we've made the selection here
this is now expressed as this expression
where
depths are greater than 520
meters i guess
and less than 673 meters and then we
could
using this filter method we can apply
that to our data set to actually kind of
okay i've made some selection i now want
to work with that subset of data that
i've actually selected right
um so that's pretty nice uh that's just
something i wanted to show you real
quick just showing you the power kind of
seeing compositions easy
building these plots is easy but you
really get a lot more power even then
right and this this works with a huge
range of plot types including kind of on
these really large data sets millions or
billions of data points that you're
plotting with data shader as well
all right now let's get back on track um
this is i think probably the last
notebook we're going to get to there's
quite a lot more content in this
tutorial and i encourage you afterwards
if you're interested to keep running
through it kind of we get into kind of
building actual applications
and so on um but for now i'm going to
take you through this interactive
pipelines notebook which is going to
introduce you to some very powerful
easy apis to build
some apps
okay so the first thing we're going to
do is import panel
panel is a dashboard library we've been
building
which makes it really easy to kind of
prototype
interactive components in a notebook and
then deploy that separately so i'm going
to show you some affordances um that
that provides
and then we're going to dive into kind
of this hvplot interactive api
to dig into kind of what we can actually
practically do with that very easily
so
panel objects again just render
themselves in a notebook here we get
this widget
that reflects the current value is
reflected into python right if i set it
from python
it's also reflected into the front end i
can kind of to demonstrate that this
isn't tied to jupiter in any way i'm
quickly going to basically launch a
separate
this show call here creates a running
server which you could kind of run
entirely separately from jupiter and
serves this
as a separate application right
um and so in if you wanted to deploy
this you could easily deploy this um
obviously a single widget isn't
something you would
want to apply but
some of the apps that we're going to see
and build now might be something you
want to share
um
yeah so if you play around you can see
if if we kind of change the value of the
slider and then rerun this cell you'll
see it'll be reflected um in python
okay
we're going to again run our imports
load our data
uh kind of pre-process our data a little
bit and just to get it in a nicer format
for working with right we're just going
to select the columns we're interested
in we're going to kind of select just
data that falls within kind of nice
geographical limits we can ignore kind
of
polar and
yeah
earthquakes in the polar regions just to
have a slightly nicer data set okay and
now comes the magic part right
by importing
hp.pandas we've added this second
accessor so access is the hp plot
accessor is the
plotting entry point this is the entry
point for building data pipelines data
apps
very easily from pandas data frames
so this interactive call here
basically returns a new object
which is now an interactive object so if
i check the type of this this is now an
interactive object it wraps the data
frame
but now we can do really quite fun and
interactive things with this thing right
so previously we created this magnitude
slider and now we can
do some expressions such as
we're going to filter
this data frame
with the slider and this is just
standard pando's syntax right that you
if you've used pandas before this is
something you're going to be familiar
with and we're going to say
for all magnitudes filter this data
frame and give me just the magnitudes
that are greater than the value of this
current slider and so as i drag the
slider now
we can see this data frame updates
so we've built a data up in a single
line of kind of very idiomatic python in
fact pandas code and this is using the
exact apis that you're familiar with
and this interactive api works not just
with pandas but with all the other
libraries that we were talking about
before
dask x-ray and so on
um so
using the api as you you already know
you can now build data apps in your
browser link
kind of your selections
uh to your data frame
or to your plots right and so now we
have we use the standard.plot api again
i will create a histogram plot and as i
drag the slider we see this plot now
update
and so
super interactive super easy um and
using just the apis that you already
know um so
here we've now swapped out our um mafia
lib plot for this hdb plot
and
yeah we can build this
little application very very easily
um so other things we can do
is filter
by dates for example
uh so here we have this date range
slider in panel
uh we're gonna get
basically gonna
set the start and end to the maximum
date and the last date in our the
minimum and the maximum date in our data
set
um
and now we can kind of
okay we can look at that the
start date the end date
and
this thing has
so-called
it has two parameters called value start
and value end which as you might imagine
is the current value start and end value
of this
date range slider so as i change that
we see that update
and now again we can kind of do
arbitrarily complex expressions on our
data set with these widgets
the kind of new thing here is that
really um
what we're working with is not the
widgets themselves
um but actually parameters on this
widget and so
underneath this
kind of magicness of selecting with a
widget
lies the fact that actually these
widgets have parameters
these parameters in this case are called
value start and value end
and that's
how things are actually filtered
whenever the parameter changes and
notify is interactive that the parameter
value is changed and that the plot
should be updated in response
um and so now we kind of have this
complex expression where we can filter
both by magnitude and by a time range i
can drag that around and we can build
this interactive app pretty easily
so now let's try
you guys have a go at it uh
created quick x do a quick exercise
where
we filter by
the minimum magnitude
um but in this case actually use the dot
param value accessor to filter instead
of
the widget itself
that's a really important uh
understanding uh in panel in particular
you can kind of
everything is a parameter and so you can
link everything to everything else so
understanding that kind of the parameter
is what links the thing is very
important
so we don't have any solutions here
um so i'm just going to work through
this
myself as well
and so we start with our
dfi which is the interactive data set
we
say dfi dot
mag
is greater than
thank you
is greater than
max slider param that value
and this is basically underneath it all
it's equivalent
to just doing this filtering
okay
the nice thing the other nice thing
right is that we're building pipelines
here we don't have to stop kind of we've
kind of built built our filter data
frame
um
but we don't need to stop there right we
can we can create other things we can do
further analyses we can chain
our
pipeline or analysis
into further analyses and so we've kind
of stored this interactive pipeline as
this filtered variable and now we can
create some plots from it so we're going
to kind of create a plot of the hv plot
magnitude
using hp plots create histograms
of the magnitudes and depth
and then we can as you see it
automatically kind of displays the
sliders that are in this pipeline
such that when i drag we now update both
of these plots
because
hp plot can track
that
these are inputs to our pipeline and so
we're going to expose those widgets for
you
so pretty cool just in a few lines again
we've built
this interactive application
that filters this data
the other thing
so this is all very centric on
filtering
really hp plots so i'm going to go off
script a little bit here
really
any method
can be can be made interactive in this
way
so i might do kind of a rolling mean
[Music]
rolling
and
have a window here
window parameter right
widgets dot
and slider um
start
and 10
call it window
and now i can kind of
use that as an argument to any function
on
that you might be used to when you're
working with pandas
uh
sorry about that
so
yeah so in this case i guess that i
should have used something like resample
oh it doesn't like that sorry about that
um we should have used of course
weekly i should use a selector like
weekly or bi-weekly
so i could create a select widget here
to say
basically one day
one week
and now
i could do hp plot
all right
all right
all right uh
plop the magnitude again
okay so
we can kind of create any interactive
pipeline that we want
and
uh interactive will interpret any widget
or parameter as an interactive thing to
bind to this this pipeline
all right
so as a last step we're going to kind of
create this interactive map
so again
we subset our data beforehand to give us
a more manageable dataset to work with
and now we create an interactive
pipeline from the subset again filtering
by date filtering by
the magnitude
and then feeding that into this
geographic plot um
and just the same we can now kind of see
that should not be flickering
um
we'll have to look at that um we can
create this interactive plot uh that
updates so kind of if we can we filter
down to a single data point there
we might just select
uh magnitudes above 6.5 and see kind of
the most the strongest earthquakes
so you can kind of i hope you can kind
of see that you can build really really
complex
applications very very easily using this
approach
um one thing that we haven't covered so
far is kind of
so far we've whenever we kind of
displayed this pipeline uh
these widgets appeared automatically
right um but in actual fact you might
wanna when you're building an actual
application and you wanna make it look
pretty right you don't want your widgets
right above your plot you want to kind
of lay them out nicely and so on
which is something that the panel
library which
can do for you and if you kind of follow
the tutorial a little bit further
we'll show you how that works and so to
do that you kind of need to understand
that
when we display it
it kind of terminates the pipeline right
it says now we're rendering this thing
and
we're going to display the layout of
this entire thing
but there's a number of terminating
methods which basically
turn these objects into
the objects that are actually
rendered underneath it all right and so
one thing we can do for example is kind
of terminate this pipeline into hollowvs
objects and so if i call dot holoviews
we get all of these objects which you're
familiar with from kind of the com the
previous composing plots section
um which then allows us to kind of layer
on top other things such as uh the
link selections that we saw before so
now i can build a pipeline that
kind of is filters or pre pre
aggregates your data or does any other
pandas operation terminate it into a
hollow views plot and then apply link
selections such that we can now kind of
have this interactive pipeline where i
can filter my data so we're going to
unfilter kind of include some more data
again we're going to select the subset
and all of this combines to give you the
power of kind of all the power that
that's available in the holo of a zika
system
so
as you can see it's still linked to
these widgets it's still linked through
these link selections and that's really
quite powerful
so the main terminating methods are
these widgets
so you can get access to the widgets
yourself you can get access to the
holidays all of these objects so you can
do things like link selections and
but you can also kind of terminate and
say actually i want
um
from this filtered sub range i want the
whole layout
and this is now a layout of
the data
and the widgets
and if we print that this is actually a
panel object panel again is this
dashboarding library we've been
developing
and you can see here it explains exactly
kind of this is a layout
a row of
containing a column of our widgets and
our
in this case just the view of the data
um how are we doing on time
12 minutes i do want to leave a little
bit of time for questions at the end
but yeah i hope you kind of
got an idea of the power that
this api provides right
you don't need to relearn new apis to
build your interactive applications you
just use uh the apis that you're already
familiar with you sprinkle in this
interactive
call
and then the pipeline works just the
same like a pandas pipeline
pandas method chaining works except now
you can provide parameters or widgets as
the inputs
so
i'll quickly demo
since we do have a few minutes i'll
quickly run through
where we can go with this right
um
towards um
i may actually
instead of going kind of off off field
and
introducing another concept i'll dig in
a little bit more some other things you
can do with interactive um
so you're gonna have to watch me live
code a few things
so
so far we've kind of only seen in this
interaction in these interactive
pipelines um the ability to
link widgets or parameters directly with
our interactive pipeline right but what
happens
what would happen if you want to
transform your widget input before you
feed it into this interactive pipeline
right so maybe i want um
the title of this plot here
to be to reflect the current magnitude
selection and the current date selection
right
and so
if i wanted to basically set the title
parameter of this thing
how do i now do this well there's
there's a solution
in
panel provides something called
a bind function and we'll see how that
works in a second um so here we're going
to do
create a little function that formats
our title for us right
so we've got the magnitude
we've got our dates which is the start
date and the end date of our filter
we're now going to create a little f
string to say
[Music]
earthquakes
with magnitude greater than
mag
and between
dates zero and
dates
one
okay
um
so if i were to call if i now call this
function right i could do
i've got my mag
slider value i've got my
date sub-range
[Music]
oh i didn't re-execute this
let me do that
so yeah in this way we can kind of
format
our title but now how do i pass this
into this interactive pipeline well this
is where
pn.bind comes in in a bind basically
means bind these arguments to this
function and so in that way we can kind
of express
complex complex things about
these values that we're putting in
and so now we're going to bind
to this title function the magnitude
slider and the
[Music]
date sub range slider
and so whenever
either of these sliders changes
panel.bind will tell the interactive
function here
to call this method again and update the
title right
so in this way we now have a title
which is linked
to the magnitude
or not
a demo effect here apparently oh this is
probably not the correct
okay
max up range
yeah i give it the wrong slider so we
want max up range
and now whenever i
change the magnitude
not just does the plot updates but also
it calls this function
with these two values and recomputes the
title and so in this way we can kind of
create any arbitrary inputs dynamic
inputs to any function
which is quite nice
sorry okay previously just a second ago
the question was um
what did i just change uh i made a
slight mistake before right um
we have multiple magnitude sliders here
we have the date sub range and the
magnitude sub-range i'd passed in
max slider which is a slider we used
somewhere above in the notebook
so i just fixed it
okay cool
and
as um
so what we can do again here is now
we've built this little application
right using panel and if you follow the
tutorial we can now deploy this
as a nice little application
entirely separately
you can put this on your server
and kind of share your interactive
results with
other users maybe not even technical
users right who don't know how do i run
this notebook how do i work with jupyter
you can kind of share your
data science insights directly with
users
panel also has nice things such as
templates where you can kind of create a
little
application around it
earthquake let's call this the
earthquake data explorer
and i'll assign this to a variable
i'll say append our
geo
dot layout to it
and then let's show that instead
and now we don't just have
uh we get a nice little template around
it um we can do further things such as
kind of well actually i don't want my
widgets to be in the place they are
right i want um to place them in the
sidebar
geo dot widgets
and geo dot panel
oh i should probably have
that
sorry
i should have re-executed that and now
we have this uh we've basically created
a nice little templated application uh
it has features such as kind of resizing
and all of that in just a few lines of
code right
again we've just created our little
template added our widgets to the
sidebar added our plot to the main area
and created a dashboard that you can
share with anyone
i think i'll call it a day here um i do
encourage you to
kind of follow through um the next
sections will kind of take you through
some of the basics of using panel
kind of combining hp plot panel and
hollow views in in powerful ways
and then finally take you to building
full dashboards
yes absolutely sorry about that
yeah the question was go back to the dm
command please
yes
okay so i guess we have a question round
now then it sounds great a few questions
from online some of them were already
answered
on
um discord so let's start with the ones
which haven't been answered yet
okay
what is the status of hollow whiz
compatibility with other ides for
instance vs code interactive mode spider
pycharm etc that's a very good point so
generally
we love notebooks we i kind of all our
documentation is centered around
notebooks we work well in
soviets code also has notebook
integration it works in there
but if you do not like to work in
notebooks for whatever reason there's
very valid reasons not to like notebooks
you can use um
panel to kind of have a auto reload
function where you just script in once
on one screen and see the result
reflected on in the browser on another
screen
and that's a perfectly valid way of
working um we may have to kind of
improve the documentation around that a
little bit um if you look at there's a
nice little blog post for the last panel
release which kind of walks
through that
a little bit um i think auto reload is
in here yes um
oh no it's not
so sorry about that um but there is uh
the functionality you kind of you start
a server
you point it to a particular script and
then it automatically refreshes whenever
you save the script so that's a
perfectly valid and nice way of working
with the stack
okay so i quickly go through some of the
questions that were
answered on this chord very quickly can
i put another image in the background
instead of the map the answer is yes all
of you underlying so use the
multiplication dunder c hollow way or
whole view overlays
next question i deliver most of my plots
using pi simple gui do you know if these
plots will show there the answer was
probably but you haven't tried yet
and it can be used a3 plot with jupyter
lab the answer is yes yes and if you
have any problems then
i think you can ask either on the
official channels or in
any questions from the audience or
anything you would like to add to these
questions i just read out before no
those were great questions thank you
another question about compatibility how
does hp plot work with streamlit do you
have to work with streamline so i think
um streamlight does have support for um
embedding
plots okay plots that's correct so in
the end it's just a bucket plot i showed
you that command earlier right uh if you
import all these uh import hall of views
and then render to a bucket plot that
should work directly we do need to talk
a little bit more with the
streamlight devs
unfortunately streamlit does not have
the same kind of bi-directional
communication that panel for example in
the bookie server provide and so a lot
of the interactive features
of kind of
dragging sliders the interactive
selections on plots that kind of stuff
won't work
um
when you said you can share now your
plot with somebody else and they can
interact with that do you mean you have
to first deploy it somewhere and then so
there's a there's a few options there
the standard way is
the standard way would be to kind of yes
basically stand up a server
but it's integrated in panel
so you basically just run panel serve
and point it to the notebook
and then that deploys it as an
application or you can move it to the
script
there's alternatives so if kind of
if it's a fairly simple simple app there
is an option to kind of embed all the
states into the application itself and
so i can try it here
yeah
so
by calling this embed function on this
panel object it kind of goes through and
kind of pre-records
the states as i drag these sliders
i don't think it actually supports it
doesn't support all the sliders
and so now this could be shared as in as
a static html file
i have also been exploring so if you've
heard today there was a talk about
jupiter light which is a
version of jupiter that runs entirely in
browser i've been exploring the ability
to actually run
panel applications in pyodide which is
what jupiter light is built on
so you will very soon be able to kind of
deploy
panel applications entirely as uh
browser-based uh applications
so one more quick question
can be two
only one okay uh
the hv port supports streaming data
uh we just stream that uh are there some
limitation or restriction which
developers should be aware of
in general it works quite well uh there
is various examples i hope um on the hp
documentation of using
the streams library
um if you kind of need more control you
kind of do have to drop down to the
hollow views api
which makes it possible to have
so-called streams themselves so you can
create a
for example a pipe
which is just some data and then you can
pipe that into your plot um so in this
case i could i don't know put my data
frame in here
uh create a
curve that kind of is fed by the stream
so there is good support for it
if you find issues please report them
but yeah as a starting point i would
recommend playing with the streams
library
[Music]
and just seeing how far that gets you
all right thank you very much thank you
for presenting let's thank our speakers
again for this interesting tutorial